all right so we are here in the studio
for another play the people episode and
unfortunately it is Jeanette Boros today
who's running just slightly late so we
do have a special guests here in the
studio Rebecca Buffington who's our
event coordinator manager superstar
extraordinaire the title goes on it's a
really long title so she can't even have
a business card because yeah but that
early yeah that's all the things that
she does around double-sided and so what
we're doing here just the Rebecca knew
is we're playing as you can see here on
my chest people can see that we are
streaming now so we're gonna just go
ahead and play a game while we wait for
finish and so if you click on this light
chest that organ thing we can go ahead
and we'll just start a game and then we
can keep talking just say like oh yeah
okay
and then people are challenging us
before the grandmaster and he'll just
play all the people so you're playing
some 1400 here okay and then so they're
gonna make some movie then we'll just
play a game and then when Dennis gets
here we'll see what time control he
wants to play and I am NOT a grandmaster
okay that's totally fine so we'll see
what you come up with so okay
[Music]
sure is that it okay I thought you're
gonna go one square but you wouldn't
what a little bit far yeah yeah so now
they develop upon and their Bishop is
attacking you or fun mmm okay so then
what would okay yes yeah who is the
Grand Master I'm good to see you chest
as my love we're starting to get people
in here the Grand Master today will be
Danish more oh sure we'll be here right
now we are watching the musings of
Rebecca Buffington as she takes us
through yeah I'm kind of copying the
person that I'm playing I'm not sure
what to do so it's been a while since
I'd play chess usually I am running
around making sure everyone else's
events are going well and so I don't
have a lot of time to watch or enjoy the
game of chess but yeah what do you think
Jonathan keep bringing your stuff oh did
I yeah usually when you move that Jeep
on it's a signal your bishops gonna go
to Jesus every day I'll do that so and I
don't know what time control the Grand
Master will want hopefully we do get
them in here but maybe 500 is a good way
to start but challenges to whatever and
we'll see what he picks
if you take that it is protect twice so
now I can take your night with you there
that was not fun okay alright alright
but if you played d6 maybe they'll take
with the pawn and you'll take their
queen that would be exciting
alright are you coming in come on in we
got lots of people here and my two best
friends Ryan Chester and Beth Deacon
come say hi hi guys okay well I need
some help though I'm not for you oh yeah
it's gonna be hard to save this one but
combined power of the chess club that's
right mm oh he just took my yeah wins on
the same diagonal as your rook so you
better like bring your night out and I
got that diagonal there that nights
gonna make some discovery and liquids
gonna take your rook all right hey
Baku's good to see you again
all right now they're attacking f7 which
is that square like a lot yeah so it's
detective i9 to Bishop you should defend
it somehow by drawing upon in the way
probably that one yep
and yes you can guys can kind of see -
we're changing the layout a little bit
every time we're just improving little
by little so you can see our stream
schedule over there all those times are
Central Time
here in San Francisco yep so they
cancelled so somehow you got to get your
Bishop into the game okay you'll have to
move one of the pumps that are blocking
your bishop and get your bishop out
right in this shaking his head we got
Ryan Chester here in the studio
undefeated crushed everybody yesterday
oh wow look you already got a donation
because we got Rebecca look at that one
bit from the ghost of Banquo what does
that mean
also some people have said oh my god
it's a girl spelled gril Gral
whoa hi boys I don't know if you want to
encourage it but hey HS just as well as
oh cool you mentioned you have an
amazing tournament coming up the Karen's
Cup that will be February 2nd through
February 17th so we hope you all will
come down
I do not know who's playing in it yet
yes it's gonna be some of the top two
females in the whole world so it's gonna
be a really cool event so it's kind of
like modeled after the Sinquefield Cup
but uh but all female right so it's
gonna be that's a pretty big one a great
slate of ten female players yep and
we'll be doing the full commentary Jenny
ah sir Maurice doing all the stuff we'll
have live commentary here at the club
people will be getting tickets for it
we'll have snacks and drinks and all
kinds of stuff like that for you all and
it'll be a lot of fun so really cool
experience so if you guys are in st.
Louis in February I believe the first
round is on the 3rd that sound right
there's the six there's stuff going on
from like the first to the sixth round
is on February 6 February 6 alright and
that's a Wednesday all right so it's my
turn again
oh well because what's the hundred bits
look at that that's more than the last
Ryan in my stream all to put together
oh you're passionate yeah so I think
each bit is about like a sentence II
just mean that I wear
nice I just made $1 for us awesome good
to hear all right so what should I do
now this is why is that lit up green
like that so that was the last one that
was the last night you know that person
was on a square h do in the winter yeah
that Bond's attack so protect it or move
it or just develop your bishop something
like that your brain goals are to get
your pieces out protectively okay okay
good chess mind is asking our
tournaments usually in the evenings most
of them at least these big events like
this they always start at 1:00 p.m. our
time so that's that's central time here
in the US
each subsequent bit donation will be a
hundred times the former exciting
hmm one trick put this rook on c8 place
c5 and then hopefully we trap that
Bishop now okay and by way I mean maybe
get some material back yeah okay this is
good okay so yeah your queen is attacked
all right oh no but the Queen also
defends a knight and it's all about to
fall apart well well now what am I
supposed to do the Queen's attacked
that's the most important thing so
sounds like you got a mover you know bad
stuffs gonna happen cuz he's gonna take
a knight and that's gonna take a rogue
yeah it's gonna be bad oh great way to
be positive
oh yeah the nest will be playing very
shortly I'm sorry I realize I'm not as
exciting as a real Grandmaster but no
this is good this is this is what most
chess games look like then Queen will
take your queen we don't take my going
there that's a big room because you're
I'm screwed
yeah you probably got to put your clean
back to defend your night somewhere yeah
just make sure your queen defends your
knight and then if that knight takes
your rook you can take it back with the
bishop so you have these two dark
squares e7 and e8 would protect your
knight so it's robably not the worst
damaged white could have been in there
yeah yeah well I probably could have
crushed us a little bit better you can
take bishop why is this got it i will
donate 100 bits each time Rebecca wins a
game oh oh you might be waiting around
for a while okay
all right that sounds good to me oh snap
okay all right so I'm gonna move back
right cuz it's all about the king yep
you gotta keep the king safe yeah so
we're down a ton of stuff but hopefully
if we can somehow get some activity your
king is gonna have to go to gym get out
and who knows obviously I'm gonna need
to take some more lessons from some of
our great writers here at the chest and
lub in case you guys didn't know we have
chess instruction as well
over here at the Chess Club is the GM
ready busy on deck he's if he's watching
this I am so sorry yeah I think all
right my sure used to it we make them
analyze all these amateur games every
week in our viewers Choice class so
they're used to seeing really really bad
games oh great so of course this is
again yeah yeah I think people do get
too worried about how the Grandmaster
feel they have to say see games like
this all times as normal
also so Baku's oh he gets a little one
with a thing because these are like best
cheer of the day that's pretty cool he
gets a little gold medal next to his
name it's not telling me where now it's
good
Oh cuz we move the night because the
pager they got it so if you'd yeah just
get your look into the game throw it
somewhere
take a night hope for the best maybe
yeah try to say I'm like an open file
but then isn't nice and that gonna take
me so go there it's pretty I'm like yes
that's okay cuz then at least it's more
open or wait no wait can't say that this
is treat hopefully we have a six second
delay yeah I'm gonna do that yeah so
you're queens attacked and your pin
tonight got attacked again and if you
take it with a mom that rooks gonna take
your queen so it's getting remarried and
grimmer and grimmer i guess you have to
agree into d8
the queen yeah why would I do that
that wasn't d8 and now you've
accidentally free now yeah I've lost it
yeah alright the night singing take it
the night the night take the night
Vaughn takes name ah I see
okay alright Hank oh I got it they're
singing out there with no production who
tell make a few points we're talking
point okay nothing playing this could
save the [ __ ] alright but uh maybe
Fabiano Caroline I could save it though
I'll bet who knows probably not though
this is like a braid arrabal alright
yeah
who is has good advice never resigned
especially I have totally lost position
alright guys thanks you know people do
what you could blender his Queen on the
next move and then you never know what
would happen yeah yeah just make sure
it's protected wherever you put it make
sure it's like safe another Tecton okay
yeah that I'll see ya the basics are you
put your pieces where they can't be
attacked
alright so now black attacked your
knight twice because there's a battery
of the Queen and the bishop so they're
gonna play Queen takes Knight check
and I don't see anything great for you
to do about it so dings what about this
are still so that hangs your Brooke oh
yeah we gained a lot of encouragement
you know people are saying there's lot
of beginners that started streaming on
Twitch yeah yeah I met I'm a beginner
beginner but uh ah yes I've seen the
Grandmaster emerge now quick run away no
he can't he can't you see this position
it's yeah you think yeah it's a 1400 key
you get you can take this 14 so you want
to start your stream if it is my second
has not done a very good job I'm just
gonna say get out she's supposed to be
helping out right guys it's hard to save
this yeah I got nothing so if you run
out of time though you lose so you got
just play some random move all right bat
no that was random yeah that was totally
random take my pawn yeah so the Knights
attack twice I'll see your bishops
hanging you do a lot of mean things so
it's terrible I should have moved my
bishop because now the Queen's gonna
take it right yes yeah there yeah yep
one of the buildings yeah like go here
sure yeah okay yeah but then it's gonna
be Eric yeah get rid of all your pawns
maybe you'll somehow get stalemated so
that's your last resource you want to
try to get still in it so just there's a
the only pawn they can move just like
pushing hope for magic magic still
making yeah okay okay moving back sure
is that better or worse it's all done
it's all what would you do if you were
me people want to say though pawn
sacrifice here he's like where's women
never resign why is it red there's no
come on in come behind us so people see
I mean Mike you literally
oh okay I understand that part just
hanging there 100 had a mate see we
embarrassed this 1400 if they had a mate
and they missed it how embarrassing that
would be really embarrassing for them
it's a good thing we don't know who they
are right yeah this was just a random
person so then there's three people
already in the queue what time control
were you open to play today whatever the
people just push upon randomly this way
yeah yeah I can't wait them to steal me
and then my thing just pre move the next
pawn moves and then hope they take it
like that okay where's there's something
something still mate where where is it
you might still mate yeah could king of
somewhere oh I'm not feeling okay so you
have half a seconds you gotta just you
better like this yeah that's closer than
knows what would happen all right well
thank you got to play your first game
I'm sorry no so you have to be like she
got all these donations to people
donated while she was here which is so
that was that was great so thank you
everybody and thank you Rebecca so we do
have a the Grandmaster here now Dennis
Poros we'll see you Rekha and here we
have all of our challenges once you get
all miked up yep and we're just hanging
out we're playing some chess so you can
everybody take a look I'm just choosing
challenges yeah everyone's ready for 15
minutes ready to play long long games
okay how long is too long I like
anything over 15 minutes
I like ten minutes is really long if 10
is just too long guys I mean 500 is fine
you better take the five okay yeah
shortest I mean I feel like 500 is good
but if you wanna do like a ten yeah what
should I play with black well you should
play just super grandma is there
anything yeah let us know in the chat if
there's anything for
okay see I did have a crazy self-serving
idea okay
it's mostly about me and it's not oh
that I would play I don't know what to
play here oh you play Sicilian obviously
okay obviously and then you know if it
was Sicilian your play like e6 and
probably the t6 yeah
tamaño everyone's on board I wanted a
little bit for the French not too late
no no scotch the French yeah I can't
play the Platypus now but alright let's
play something yeah stuff this is the
close to Cillian it's pretty boring but
I'm still gonna have some fun I hope
oh no you're not taking my night also
nobody would get us caffeinated
beverages so if you need we got this
weird not coffee it's some keto thing
that Danny used to be into it's got like
all the fat and then but it has
hopefully caffeine so if you need me a
beverage and you too weird butter coffee
yeah we do have that so seemingly I
played horribly playing my night like 50
times and move it to d4 but at least my
opponent can open up the position with
these d4 ideas I can't even show if you
yeah I think if you're right click and
drag it right Claro's yeah yeah he would
like to play d4 but because of this
beast right here it's not possible
also people might notice since Rebecca
played we lost our GM title oh my god
now we're we're LM LM Lewis which I've
heard might actually be an improvement
there's actually less LMS than GM's out
there hmm so I don't know if it's a
downgrade or an upgrade
alright alright things are looking good
though I like this position especially
this non-participant rook
it makes me feel happy do you like the
up an exchange part of it yeah that's
also that's also pretty pleasant Oh Eric
Rosen is online so yeah every time we've
been streaming it's been Hamlin we got
Yasir Yasir yeah Wow
so people if you know if you don't
people to look over here you can hover
over that window I guess I can't see it
on this one
I was so weakened we can watch Eric play
and oh we can I guess those streamers
they can't see it today
so just because of Yasir I'm pushing
pawns okay into I don't know Febby was
into taking bombs is he into pushing no
he's also in love with pushing pawns so
if you see any moves any pawn pushes
you'd like for me to do I'm happy to
push more pawns alright because LM is
better because it means light chess
thinks you're a distinguished member of
light chests I know distinguished member
is magnus and LM he's not no but we are
that we are of course so I'm considering
it an upgrade play your anti London if
you get a chance oh I will just people
to play the London but yeah that does
require my opponents to play the London
all right
hmm I like my opponent he likes donating
stuff so I'd be a rude person to reject
yeah things are looking up in the first
game yeah looks fun okay this is good
because now we're getting tons of
challenges I see it there yeah second
update yeah we're getting more and more
challenges hmm but yeah this is the
austere challenging so that's one thing
we would like to do is actually have
instead of play the people it's a
challenge against oh they're yeah like
somebody oh yeah something which would
be cool idea
all right dr. Snoopy has called it a day
here oh no he's down a lot of scary
signs why we just start I just you plus
4 you know I'm stronger than a GM you're
an LM okay thank you for the game thank
you thank you doctor Snoopy banana-trama
good name good tough ones in here there
are some tough ones you wondering okay
knowledge I won that play button are AMA
cuz that's a good song so how should I
start my game usually you push a pawn in
the middle o the middle yeah it's one of
those - all right let's well okay let's
I'm I can you Mel slope dude I miss that
yeah so now what I guess gonna still
remedy this situation mmm f4 this was an
aggressive approach no no for a 1d 3
player this is a unique flavor oh my god
I'm gonna play like Fischer suddenly
even though which is strange for a 1d 3
player castling is always nice because
then you don't lose immediately probably
not suppose I'm building a house right
here
and no one can stop me see this is a big
big temple that I built but I want to
mate so oh whatever
whoa that's aggressive yeah maybe a bit
too aggressive but no felt right
I want to jump around like a
Clown Posse yeah I just want to jump on
this bomb you're down upon the oh my god
your attention oh my god I don't know if
you noticed this will be bad if I can't
capture d3 too strong this is because
see see I'm building phanpy families
later ethically though yeah you know you
lure them in with one but it's the
intention is checkmate yep
I start the tricky one move just to
attack later yeah good
come on he's gonna take your palm oh my
god no I like this I like giving check
because usually it leads to me yeah
that's a good move mmm two minutes -
well the layout has approved - thank you
essential yeah we're gonna keep making
improvements and we actually have two
people in the studio here Danny and
Isaac are with us today making sure this
whole stream Danny takes place so yeah
yeah we keep getting better and better
all the time yeah thank you Bananarama
yeah thank you been in there Emma
actually I was unfair though you played
your best stuff yeah but a bit is like a
donation or something so each one is
worth like a cent so Rebecca got a
hundred bits donated so it's like a
dollar so yeah alright are you gonna
make a little cameo appearance I think
they went full screen so we don't see
Ryan good really keep that guy off the
screen so might opening should I played
come on chat tell us yes tell us give us
some ideas against e4 and d4 because I
suppose yeah I have no idea right now
Yaser if you have any idea that was yes
sir someone just just call up Yasser
tell him the challenges yeah yeah yeah
if you can't hear Ryan DS maybe maybe he
has a pager we can beat them
hi I told you the first one was gonna be
bonk loud cuz obviously okay Alec I'm
French
Albin counter gambit for the cameraman
though great job actually I play that
looks just like last week against seve
on and I drew so okay so what kind is
not losing yet it's already decent yeah
Benoni okay so we have are you Ella kine
and Benoni I mean would you really
disrespect the anonymous Rhino enough to
play the bonk load against him no I
would never disrespect an anonymous
rhino but also he might not be here
right now yeah my opponent yeah good
exit really which one is not the next
don't read Barney it's so complicated I
know
do you not play only just well these are
all right let's play wonder King oh my
god that let's let's build a fan base
for one day three okay
Oh what to do now d4 is a bad move let's
do B 3 is that the theory
well we're building it right now okay
your people obviously like the Carlson
variation here if you're into that yeah
so it's interesting opening played in
some arena yeah on this very site so I'm
playing this double fianchetto thingy
okay but I don't know if it's it's
decent it's not winning but it's Jewish
94 here whoa you scared me there now
actually my opponent isn't some whatever
trouble cuz he has these terrible
doubled pawns now which I hope to use
later on all right
he seems good enough
mmm-hmm progressive
yeah pretty convinced d3 it's a good one
hi mr. drive mr. drive
mr. jive jive Oh J yeah you saying hi
guys hey hey what's up do you like my 1d
3 I'm convinced about the viewers they
kind of mix yeah yeah first game I
wasn't sure but now I know it's just
checkmate if they play positionally
they're just worse so yes of my idea is
to hit on this pawn and soon I want to
use some tactical tricks but first let's
play some positional chess so I'm just
fixing this pawn on c5 forever and the
c6 will be weak as well so in the long
term if I get to pile another piece like
this that will be the end of it I've
been a 1.d4 player my whole life guess
I've been going too far over extension
yeah I did this oh my god a blunder they
exchanged but ok I'll get this long
diagonal no bars asking are you
Hungarian I am definitely Hungarian
Kirsten I'm a catfish alright that
proves it yeah my guess my Hungarian
wasn't flawless but ok I'm still trying
let's take this where did you grow up I
grew up in Budapest not Prague but
Budapest
ok which is a totally different country
but
I mean it's a good quiz question but if
they ask you it's the Czech Republic
you heard it here so I am down an
exchange but I have these beautiful
beautiful bishops so if I don't flag
somehow I still should be winning
I assume all right let's keep our pawns
takes a lot of guts to play this d3
system does it I know you're just more
aggressive player than one bar was well
okay my queen is not the best piece I
admit but maybe in the near future it'll
be even better alright let's go let's
roll
so far that d3 pawn is calm yeah all the
way to d5 even though it's not judging
was that it knows the d4 or rides yeah
play the Hungarian open I think that's
I'm Gary and opening is that what this
but there's so many there's the budapest
gambit yeah and there's a bit of us
variation playing against me in a
tournament they did this last weekend
yeah Oh attack somehow beat at
twelve-hundred myself act ah I am rosin
he said Budapest with lots of hearts ah
see Eric vo love glitter pests I mean
yeah least I do and look Eric's no
longer streaming or online or something
he's not watching us good good hi Eric
how's Thailand oops
shouldn't have said that but but let's
push this palm
[Music]
Thailand is tasty as I am Rossum I can
believe that tasty
that's not bad good all right Aliona
cadets are you taking rook
that's sacrifice but you already said
one exchange not many Brooks we don't
know you don't need rooks rooks are
overrated
I mean I'll take it if they give it to
me that's also 4:30 a.m. for Eric Rosen
so he's taking off good to see Eric
thanks for putting in just to say hi
have a good night
should I promote to rook okay let's see
for me good night he did a taxes know
that okay all right well done yeah let's
see yeah thank you for the game was
interesting
all right and then trying to play the
ones that say rated to our rating lose
them
oh okay yeah in general everyone should
make it rated they won't want to
everyone wants to play casual okay you
know you're some GM with like an 1800
rate every one of us plays on this okay
but alright well yeah if you play right
in the nose I like this guy cuz he
sounds distinctively Hungarian but my
big question is should I continue with
my d3 street um I need to see one more
game I think one more game okay and then
then we can for some reason it's way
some of the worst opening the doctor out
there okay yeah this is good I mean
people need to know how like we black
fient ghettos right away how do you
address the situation
yeah we're about to see it right here
chaos
yeah people requesting we play the
higher rated people 2200 loss which we
you did play the highest-rated guys on
the list yeah so hires people high
ratings to trailer dress yeah so call up
your your local 2,200 plus players I'm
to Childress alright so now I generally
would want to play b3 but because of
this beast would want to open this
diagonal but you can secondly exchange
that way how's your rook if you don't
let that Bishop - ah good point
hmm then I can sack the other book yeah
let's see
but it seems this d3 move seems to be a
huge success it's strong I take away
I think everyone's gonna start playing
this now so book up on your your anti D
3 and if cousins are watching this I
played at first right I called dibs on
one D 3 yeah but if he plays it one
bullet arena
I still call it call dibs
yeah so this looks like Swiss cheese for
my opponent in her mirror good to see
you he says please play the Italian game
okay okay and we've had on the other
streams a lot of different people and
let this inter we're saying they want do
you Talia in the season okay - oh yeah
just a disclaimer the rui lopez is way
more fun but the italian is the hype
right now yeah it's okay it's
interesting but the rule apes' is better
i want to strike whoa atactic encouraged
it should i still play it well he didn't
see it so it's okay let's play it let's
that does it be fair and then it's hard
to know how big the delay is so I'm
looking up there I'm gonna weigh up just
myself so I think it's it's not that big
of a delay so I can be listening to us
okay but I mean yeah I mean I did not
tell them exactly yeah so the trick is
if he takes my pony then I can take his
rook you can just pray move it if we
move it you think that's not gonna
happen I promise you he's thinking too
much it's awesome wait I just watched
the Grandmaster he sacked in exchange I
know what's up she's gonna blender of
rook for a knight
so this pinguin guy is online yeah
challenge him penguin guy he's too
strong nah that's okay I just drew a
twenty seven hundred and a live game so
I don't don't feel no feel scared right
yeah yes yeah let's play my name is Joey
what's up Joey
my name is Dennis what about Joey and
you may not believe this fact but he did
reveal to us his name is in fact Joey
oh wow actually my real name is Dennis -
but how do you actually say your name
well you'd say Danish but it's basically
a Greek name so it doesn't matter how
you say it another Bishop hanging yeah
it's kind of hanging but you have a
technic
I think I have a smother made him so I
think I'll just go for it penguin is a
bullet beast indeed yeah but does
everyone love penguins I always liked
him oh my go to the zoo that's one of
the first places not always go
we like the Penguins actually like
Komodo dragons more yeah because they're
really nice not too nice with deer but
in general they're nice people if you
keep your distance if you keep me and if
you have a stick with you they're safe I
wouldn't poke you wouldn't I would not
focus moto dragon you wouldn't poke a
Komodo no no but they like human company
obviously I'm joking they're aggressive
yeah they're not aggressive they yeah
lizards are scary yeah I agree with
pneumatic scary moto dragons will eat
you adjust if they have to well if you
poke them with sticks they might they
might get in your name Bubba but the
back that I bet I do yeah that's know
anything I knew it they look good I'm
not gonna say it so everyday you see uh
smothered mate no that was a good way to
end the game thank you
come on you have to push one of the
pawns
if you push d3 yeah oh we're gonna see
the the recipe huh yes
maybe we'll see I don't know if you want
to show the recipe but okay I don't want
to give away secrets what I'm a new
challenge yeah I think I like blinks
when you like anyone only four so what
am I see what's the blouse lipped I'm a
slip yes
what do they want a budapest oh you're
the best okay I'm sorry to make you play
such a horrible opening but oh okay
thank you thank you now another mouth
slip he meant to take it yes it wasn't
too far again yeah what time control is
then accepting today it's been mostly
five minute I guess he's okay with three
two this was a casual no make I'm rated
we weren't ready to go up and our
schedule again oh my god
oh my goodness but uh yeah 503 2 maybe 3
minute that seems to be a good range
obviously I'm trying to attack like
crazy mm-hmm
all right so many secrets give some away
yeah free gift just revealing his best
stuff yeah see tactics always work but
your rooks on the same line as his
bishop at some point you can sack the
exchange yay
can't wait to sack you oh my god lose
the bishop here
this guy's great this guy's crushing you
this guy just taking all my bishops yeah
this guy's too strong with a name like
that yes such a long name ah but I have
f4 expected you expect are you coming
I knew you were coming I thought you
were just gonna play Knight takes e4 and
sac the extra oh that might be free oh
yes we're the best yeah thank you for
your donation LM title you've been too
strong yeah I thought you were okay as a
GM once he became he'll barely unlock to
your full potential
yeah I'm trying my best
so the question should I sacrifice on h3
and I guess that's a non question
because you would never I would never do
that
don't worry never be crazy yeah that'd
be crazy
all right let's let's be solid like BAM
that's just bring gar ladies with a big
long comment see if I can read it all
okay so yeah Jonathan since our
discussion the other day I decided it
was time to go back to some of your
videos perhaps some that I forgot
everything about all right excellent
hopefully they're just as helpful the
second time around I agree that's my
opinion I totally agree
Jonathan is the best why thank you very
much so I'm slightly winning here I
think that's all I can say yeah this is
I'm threatening to take the pawn also
this typical Kings Indian sacrifice is
coming hope I don't resign by accident
you can probably sack too when you're
already up everything yeah the only way
to know is to look over there plus seven
plus seven that's a lot so I guess - so
your residency just started today so
you'll be teaching the two classes
tonight yeah there's viewers choice
where you'll be analyzing sort of the
beginner games that people have
submitted so you guys can keep sending
those in - info at st. Louis just go to
work and if you have some ideas for
romantic games yeah cuz then that - yeah
yeah the second classes games from the
Romantic era yeah so people might have a
favorite or something they want to
analyze and if you send poems
I'll read it - okay that's no that's a
bummer
that's a little tree our that's a
promise because it's the Romantic era
that's a good point
I don't think he's talking I don't think
I'm joking all right that's and then you
have to teach what is for many GM's
the most dreaded class we've ever had my
greatest losses on Thursdays oh yeah how
do you feel about that class I actually
played some really good players okay I'm
not sure many people heard of them I
don't want to really spoil okay but you
got some if you lost some good games i
love it are you okay with showing them
i'm thrilled thrilled okay yeah i feel
like a lot of grandmasters might have a
different opinion but oh my god okay
with it yeah so excited thank you yeah
great games anyone all right
what is this eye net like what is a
rating that has I'm 2700 question mark
yeah I think it'd just be a provisional
like okay and enough games yet on the
site in that yeah category but I would
love to be like instead of my rating
2850 question why well if you use the
glucose system yeah it's kind of just
based on like an accuracy rain so if you
don't play for a long time your ranges
actually this huge rating points
I mean you know you're probably between
like twenty three hundred and twenty
seven hundred okay you're like in this
ring okay you're in there somewhere
okay okay so yes sir come back come back
was he on there from milk yeah you give
us here are you just watching okay I
can't believe he's not watching our
stream he's probably trying to figure
out how to challenge us right now I'm
sure yeah well that's a casual game but
I'm 100 percent sure he's Hungarian them
well that's okay Miss Ellie I guess yes
yes Hungary all right so there's be like
d3 or we hate it
or it's still let's just give him
everything at once I mean there's a
third will be back other weeks oh wow
he's saying Yanni yeah he's saying words
yeah Gary alright so which one should I
do
I just II for this okay I mean it's what
the people yeah what the people want
forget I don't know if it's what they
want mean that's just what they do
I know Italian or should we should be
faking it
and Sicilian he's just played III
Transpo's no no no we can't all right
always played thee for in this position
Jess tchen from inner mirror in your
class Dennis explain how a top just
chess player uses a computer chess basic
cetera doesn't really fit with the model
of the classmate yes something that's
worth doing so actually another little
bit of secret Bishop g5 was actually
prepared against Fischer by the Karpov
team but e5 is a really bad move because
I have a d5 square for free so that's
not good feels normal
it's normal it's normal but not good
play Knight h3 night a3 then push c3 and
f3 and tuck in both the Knights no no no
I'm not I'm not like well you know chief
that love a little disrespected yes yes
for our valuable waters yes
I don't disrespect watch Watchers
enough I know many super grandmasters do
that but I think if you're a Grandmaster
you shouldn't disrespect the game it's
because you're here to celebrate the
game and I want that on my tombstone too
I'm here to celebrate the game yes okay
remember that so you're sure you want to
put that on the stone that's what he
said yeah we wouldn't want that's what I
said 100% what he wants can't take it
back now yeah for anything else just
call Perry Coulson really I'm serious
Scheck castlelong yeah let's do this
let's do this
are you here to check me let's play h4
cuz it doesn't make any sense
that's like king b1 maybe he'll take
thank you no what do you do trade the
Queens yes and try to hold an opposer
fellas
there you go take it
come on you can do it take this spot
it's free
singing it's hanging take the pawn pick
it up interested if our viewers could
help and tell them to pick up the palm
yeah I'd be agree we can hear I mean I'm
I'm not sure how many people actually
listen I try not to worry about too much
for playing yeah there's only so much
you can do yeah but it's it's barely
actually really easy to listen because
there's yeah especially when we do the
like super studio production yeah doing
I can't play Hungarian guides there's
like less of a delay for some reason
that y'all got I'm saying the same thing
he rejects I hate sleeping good to see
you hi there is that his name yeah
somebody hates sleeping okay
can you explain your pawn move c34 faker
is God well I don't want this night to
jump to d4
therefore my on the stationing on c3
some people are really worried about
your pun
my name is Joey says saying you need to
play g3 and the pone isn't hanging well
I really want to show why I want to get
you know I don't want to spoil it right
now really oh my what does that say yes
then that's yes is that appropriate yes
that's appropriate that's how you should
write proper Hungarian
yeah and this one they said the same
thing yeah yeah that's that's take the
pawn so basically I just made sure
doesn't have B for ideas so that's why I
move both of my pawns here and that was
thinking like yes true yeah I don't have
time to google translate all these words
but yeah that that means everyone's
Hungarian oh yeah
Esther I mean that's a whole market
Hungarian people that we're tapping into
yes ah so he's coming after me hopefully
get a good old fashioned opposite side
Kessler grace here probably will do and
usually somewhat loose yeah all right
let's play conservative chess
everybody loves conservative just right
right everybody loves warrants
positional chest just means you're
playing naturally
please return yep
so my dream would be something that I
don't want to spoil okay and yeah that's
the unfortunate thing because then it's
not like as educational as it could be
for the people mm-hmm what are you gonna
do if you tell them they're gonna know
yeah that's true it doesn't always help
them let me just tell them I still don't
know yeah so my plan is is to shuffle
this beast to d5 and then he'll be set
and I'll be happy and that's the point
of chess make people sad and make
yourself what's more important if one of
them isn't more important hmm
happiness is not a bad thing in general
okay so yeah doing what you want yeah
doing what you want is a good thing all
right I think I'll continue with my plan
the only thing I'm considered of is I
really don't want to blunder this Fork
cuz that would make me a tea exchange
exactly so you don't want to yeah that
that would make me really sad yeah
I don't like it that he's trying to
screw with my plans also yep
someone could text Rebecca to stop
talking so loud that door out there it's
a bit distracting for us and we don't
know what she's gonna say so we gotta we
gotta shut that door that's nice hey
Dennis Dennis LaRue can you shut that
door
all right thanks yeah come in for a
minute
yay we got Rebecca Dennis here that's
you know it's not appropriate for the
stream we have the extra dentists here
so my plan is we're doing this the real
way TriCaster yep I'm trying you see we
got all these cool new graphics of
Isaac's here yeah I'm trying to guess oh
yeah we're getting bigger and better
amazing piece but now there's a double
Dennis power in the bill yeah look
Dennis come look we just got we're up to
99 people the second Danis LaRue walks
in indeed he is the twin Kramnik student
good to see you challenge us all right
we crossed 100 100 101 people watching
that's good yeah sacrifice okay we got
promoted I believe or demo I'm not sure
so the trick is yeah take yeah yeah
thanks email from a chick I think it's
Chris Callahan yes and he said we were
playing so well that we actually got
promoted to LM was actually nice email
and it said like yeah so usually I would
be like a mistake I married about this
and of course we know I have at the
defense it's a lot rarer to BLM than GM
I agree so oh look at how many John
Bartholomew is here hey John complain
hey John
come play I'm sure he's watching our
stream right now and he can come join us
yeah go ahead
yeah hey Rick play a little shorter this
five five three that's not getting it
done for me I'll do like five overrated
or three two well um the shorter the
better yeah yeah I've decided I decided
if I plus 3 this is too long for me okay
I think five O or three two of those are
good options and make it read it because
we want all your points yes yes Kissin
I'm Kissin um yeah yo yo Johnny a beanie
daredevil knows me Kalamata meaning you
should have gone with pong before
instead of eight four just I wanted to
show off my Hungarian skills yeah all
right you got your title taken away no
we got promoted
we got a better title motion all right
so Kramnik student just here yeah yeah
we had the option we said of course all
right so are we going with the d3
trained armies our guy I played d4
against this guy
Sol so just okay let's do this okay all
hail Moors evich this is pure violence
violent yeah we can get a French here
haha no more French I don't know if this
is good but he might not know the French
maybe he didn't mean that to happen haha
so basically we just he's trying to play
the French and I'm trying not to play
the French yeah whenever I look at these
lines with the computer they're like
this is really dumb for white but in
practice I've always found like you just
get good positions practical opening
it's the veresov which is or chin
hadashah or something in Russian so very
good whatever
some people are worrying that you've
upset been fine gold by playing f3 oh
but this is actually like a move helping
yeah and we've normal but yeah Ben's got
his rules some people yeah well I don't
people like rules cuz it's like you just
always dogmatically do it you just never
play f3 always brakeless people like
when you just tell him exactly what to
do and they just follow ya
that sounds like this is not gonna be
fun
this ain't gonna be fun not having fun
actually now I'm having fun cuz that
Bishop has no future
oh no your Kings gonna be wide open well
I like Tom mr. mumbles in the back yeah
well he's not miked so I mean what can
he do
and I think yeah sorry oh he's been
yelling I mean it's hurting my ears but
you guys just can't hear him he's not
liked is it just me is it just me you
can hang around it's fun just talk about
her if you want to Larry oh I have a
question for you yeah yeah yeah this
positions too hard yeah this is two arts
so the thing is I'm gonna play d5 Unwin
that's it
so you're thinking about am I the only
person here listening to this stream who
likes Tom Petty can't be true you like
Tom Petty I never seek him out but when
I listen to him I never complain like
yeah cuz my king is in the wide open
great wide open there you go that's
leading up for you yes okay I don't know
what you're accusing us up for but now I
know but actually it's quite safe
because he has his buddies around hey
Ryan thanks for the good words but in
general oh this Ryan like Orion no he's
a big fan of me and Eric on our YouTube
channel so it says I still no big fan of
me thanks thanks Ryan yeah I appreciate
that I don't know his feelings for you
but maybe but anyways I feel salty so
thank you and I hear that like like me I
think we were both up at 3 a.m. today so
I mean you can't help it you got me a
little salty yeah but I think we're
doing totally different stuff you
actually get up at 3 a.m.
watch well videos no that's my dream to
wake up at 3 a.m. and watch st. Louis
chess club videos yeah we can always do
it because I have to travel and I have
to play chess chess stuff yeah now it's
the worst to its naked fun yeah I have
to develop pieces when you can't
complain his way against really good
people I hate sleeping says I like you
Denis spelled Denis like you yeah
then it's like me and then it's not
Denis like him yeah
drunk lifeguard went to bed at 3 a.m.
that's what most of us are waking up
that's why we do a stream at like 3:00
in the afternoon where are you dying
some people dream of challenging us it's
not always about liking or not liking
personally English is not my first
language and I sometimes the accent
makes it difficult to understand but
Denis is not the case oh that's good
yeah thank you thank you please you're
excellent it's not tricky for foreigners
what you have is a constant issue
actually it's funny like some people
called me yet hey this guy sounds like
Adam Sandler okay I wasn't happy about
that you weren't happy
he's funny to most people if he is funny
for most people yes but actually I am in
India right now where or I am just oh
good to know yeah so you're watching the
thing that I'm dreaming of you're living
my dream yeah kudos for you yeah try to
keep your our challenges to a 500 or a
3-2 either ones fine but always rated we
want all your points give it to us
anything faster is fine rated preferred
some people say not required still what
opening is they would give me more ideas
about openings you guys want me to play
or what who you want to resort to
whatever Denis LaRue wants yeah or Denis
decide you have Danish gambit and the
Smith Maura he's gonna lose a pod the
clean thing shout-out to Alaska people
tune in in Alaska mmm I love Alaska
have you been there never been there
yeah that's why I love it
I love every place I've got a bit hello
being gambit which one is not that's the
one that only the four nights and then
bloody abuse Oh England gambit benoni
see they're gonna say all another
Halloween gambit they all digits one
gambits Kramnik student thank you for
the game yeah yeah he's a regular good
good this is good fight all of us good
fight
yeah he's strong so again what should
happen as long as you blunder upon I
think there're a soft gambit yeah self
which ones do us off D for right no no
plea for it okay flavor played them I
know before it's true--but alright yeah
Jai know the car knows bong cloud
doesn't every other alright let's make
Finn's happy okay yeah he's not watching
us but he's online
hey all right let's make him super happy
okay yes this is his love love child
Magnus plays this opening Magnus takes
it all from Finn's yeah I mean John yeah
a lot of people shout outs for the
Budapest opening which we did give a go
we played one game so if you're yeah I
played it interested this will be up on
our YouTube channel if you guys are
watching on 96 novel channel I don't
know if it's a novelty but just about
cool to say then what's up give us a
like yeah I'll have to play Bishop h5
you blended a piece oh no for your
travels Oh Dennis why did I play this
you lured him into playing g-force
have you read the never end
have you read that book of the never
ending is unbeatable
no still theory no it's not no this is
not
I made the Serie here I'm sorry yeah it
is new theory edge we're getting the
real stuff here okay i blundered upon
for compensation but okay that are you
oh my god he doesn't want it I like the
game where he was okay thank you
he took with the f on where's Ben
Feingold when you need him he didn't
play f3 but he took me yes Vaughn how
dare you how dare he I don't know what
the rule states on that or how dare she
it's true yeah I always make that
mistake do you never know what people
are say hi if you're a sheep and say hi
if you're a he - doesn't add a lot of
information but go for it yeah go for it
and if you identify as a skater that hi
- light legacy local hi I hate sleeping
- ooh blunder yes because work 400 the
guy that lost the rook or the night well
yeah Jay Matthew hmm hi yeah it's a
great place you just say say hi and like
a true society here on
happy place yeah what music do you guys
listen to a identify as an El patchy
attack helicopter can I say hi to hey
you can say so what do you guys listen
to while you're listening to this stream
as well oh that was a tricky question do
you listen to music when you play on the
Internet I lay on the internet I rarely
play on the internet sometimes I do but
I listen to more music than I play chess
on the Internet
just opening up this bishop oh I hate
sleeping just listening to dr. Dre ruin
just looking to a lot of panic at the
disco some trance music death grip at
official range angsty girls makes the
girls yeah yeah I almost read too much
of that comment yeah yeah nothing right
now just listening to your sweet dulcet
tones no thank you
hey from upstairs just add blue I don't
know who you are but just I I suppose
I'll see you as soon as the stream ends
I listened to that Yasir song pushed me
baby doing chess is a full-time job
Bach yeah Bach Bach music makes sense
that's what we listen to hear Bach the
rapper all right let's win this game all
right
did you win oh well I have as many Forks
as I like that's not a fourth work box
the techno DJ technically if you draw a
work with the arrows though we'll call
that a fork this is not a fork-mount
your opponent says well that was bad yep
yeah that wasn't too good but if you
listen to buck while playing kudos I
mean you know Bach the deejay not the
rapper not the rapper so what do you do
to study chess if you're not playing
well just
just chillin just joined I mean I do
work out I'm like physically physically
yeah okay yeah so how you improve at
Chester you yeah actually
so you you prove that Jess if you
workout because then you get fitter and
you stop thinking less about chess and
that makes you stronger
probably yeah I couldn't do the not
thinking about chess part but that's my
mistake
some people listen to karaoke carry out
their singing the whole time that their
problem just mom position too painful
thanks a lot that's your play my name is
Joey okay my name is Joey who's like
always in a chat oh just really cool and
I guess that's the sandal they don't
pronounce ya ji GI Joe alright thank you
haha that's my joy GI Joey right do they
ever call you GI Joey I would I would be
your friend but okay so okay that's 2700
that's a tiny thing it's also in this
mode the people can't see the list that
we have yes at the moment yeah alright
so if you're 2,700 please join us come
on come on you want to play em alright
Orion has been in the chat I know their
names their necks we played before
Quantic so we've played before the
stream this is early wave
Joe Cal he's been in the chair points
alright d4 well what am I suppose I not
all that high res I mean I didn't see
anyone touch you know that's supposed to
play the Dutch okay that's alright this
is a Dutch this is a dud oh sorry light
legacy if we insulted your rating oh my
god what we didn't meant to mean some
offense was in order
alright so just right to make the other
dentists happy let's do an accelerated
Dutch that's been movin this is not a
good move I just invented the
accelerated
oh they're still waiting for the England
gambit the England or the Eklund they
really want d45 all right that's all the
fun that ensues rawr
Dennis Boros talk about memorizing the
board as a key skill Jonathan I really
know what that means
it's like Dennis borrows dot dot talk
about memorizing the board as a key
skill Jonathan okay I guess it's like
Dennis what do you think about this I'm
thinking about my nest next question
Jonathan so you can you have your own
question as well to play blitz to get my
rating up to 2,000 rather than wait in
queue all right
I'd love a Latvian gambit but yeah this
Jonathan said as long as he played
gambits we will be happy okay that's
what they want
okay I don't know I mean don't ever play
this g5 move on this you're causing and
you're watching this go ahead do it I
mean if your car yakin I wouldn't object
though so just take it it's free and do
you intend to win upon yeah if he takes
I have this g4 trickery and I'll be
really happy and jumping up and down and
question form I hate sleeping when you
see a board in your head do you
visualize in 3d or 2d he's a grandmaster
4d well hope do you see a 3d board or 2d
board I think I see I think I see to
thee yeah me too I was I was hoping
you'd say 3d cuz imma be like yeah
that's why I'm not Grandmaster I only
see too deep but you guys see boards
it's not necessarily he doesn't have the
pieces of the same spots but you know
you see something here and there play a
real Queen's Gambit a real one it's like
is it all caps locked no it's just
I probably emphasize what he did me and
make it funnier okay memorizing the
board something you knew you had to
learn to get better no that's how my
brother bullied me into playing chess
yeah I made you yeah he he made me it's
like 64 of them - yeah I mean he'd make
me do stuff that seemed useless when
you're six and it's still useless when
you're 55 yeah so you heard it here
memorize the board when you're six or
you don't have a chance of being okay
yeah that's true okay
yeah you have some special like lecture
on alpha zero that was Ryan Chester
coming in no he drove look up that door
shut if Rebecca's out there otherwise
leave it open doesn't matter yes so I
already had a video on alpha zero in my
opinion and mine take on take on it but
are we going to have a special guest
very very soon so if you have questions
about that but for this letter yeah
Jacob Wilkins yeah Jacob Wilkins is late
on our protest League team so there's a
chance he's super qualified for this
topic big computer guy yes a big
computer guy so he will tell me why I'm
wrong why he thinks I'm wrong and I'll
say none and the GM's are smarter than
that
but anyways we need a lot of finger
shaking yeah a lot of fingers shaking
okay
I'm best at fingers shaking I watched a
lot of Lewis Black Sea the only reason
they don't ever want to be a grandmaster
as I can just shake my fingers yeah no
no no I'm a grandmaster seven watching a
lot of Lewis black comedies I learn how
to do that so anyway it's really really
angry yeah yes I have a fighting King
because I like fighting Kings all Ryan
asking what is more important Oh Ryan
not Ryan Chester who's sneaking stuff in
and out of the studio what is more
important for a player a sound sense of
positional or tactically sharp mind he's
asking if it's better to be positionally
minded or technically sharp well if
you're young it's better to be
tactically gifted the older you get
the better it is if you're more
positional minded and if you're like
2,600 something good games are Knicks I
didn't notice next was the stronger you
get the more important it is to know
about positional chess does everybody
knows tactics it's like if I'm looking
for tactics nobody can be the
Grandmaster of it just pure tactics
unless they blundered it right okay
probably I'm wrong but I still believe
that yeah it just seems like at some
level you get to where everybody never
sees all the tactics and yeah yeah more
important yeah but early on would you
say I mean I guess whatever these people
are the ratings have been playing them
now today and what's more important for
them more tactics tactics is the most
important part of this game because it
can it can be a whole game changer and
talking about game changers the offer
zero lecture that I'm going to have that
Jacob Wilkins it's gonna be interesting
cuz he's going to give a programmers
view and we're going to measure against
each other so if you have a question to
him or me yeah about off zero or Leela
chess and just in general general about
the alpha zero stockfish match your
opinions your thoughts about it and be
controversial because we might not meet
it anyways yeah right yeah tell us we're
not gonna read it though goodnight
Kramnik students thank you for the game
good night thank you for playing or
chatting seven another huh so yeah we've
got about 15 minutes we should have time
for a couple more yeah again our options
are limited we're down to four
challenges anyone wants to challenge us
yeah if you're truly bored you can play
whoever but yeah we should give some
people this is their last chance I mean
whatever I mean if they're low rated
let's just play them because they're
here they're watching yeah oh yeah
everyone deserves a chance all right
let's do we want to challenge it yeah
give it a go
I don't want to follow yeah hit the hit
the which one
probably the swords crossing this one
yeah
swords like oh yeah this and then does
not accept challenges yeah
you must get challenged all the time by
just people watching it except
challenges ok you try penguin yeah
not feeling as strong as you did and now
we're do I mean if we can't do that sure
obviously don't have to come it's funny
oh wait well that's way too much how
much yeah maybe he'll play three many
gamers yeah well laughs is that's 15
second encourages excessive with your
second water whatever okay yeah and he
like random little the middle Oh King
there the halfway King like okay yeah
yeah you'll see it let's see there's a
small chance that you'll see us yeah um
let me look see if he's streaming
they'll be interesting
those like he looks like he's not this
is I am sledge II don't know who use
both legs Eve jewel this guy I am sledge
II slaggy he's our competition right now
okay as well
alright look I don't see him accepting
yeah I don't know so let's see you have
to challenge him 15 seconds or less yeah
so it's looking at three two just
laughing yeah yeah that's too long for
the guy so who he's streaming puzzle
rush I've been told oh okay all right
and if you really feel weak just pick a
rated one cuz we don't wanna take all
the points to surround she and some
other points this Joe Cole he's been in
the joke oh okay Joe Cole piano England
gambit is what they want at some other
game but you have to play game it though
that's okay so that's what they want
okay so what gamut can I do against me
for f5 is a bit excessive
just play e5 and then pre-move d5 okay
actually that's not
just wanted to do d5 and then you get
your Bishop says ah he's doing my stuff
he learned it and then he can play the
c6 yeah
laughing gave me a Halloween yeah we
could have done we could have played for
those they're still always no chance
that they might actually play into all
we want I'll try to do the Italian next
my big threat is taking
all right yeah no no it was boring god
no no can't exchange screens like that
it's probably really good for you though
yeah but but okay was sock fish playing
at full strength in the match against
Alfa that's it that's a question that's
actually like the biggest debate going
on and I heard that some people say that
he spent I mean not it spent like a
little bit of time on its moves so not
too long which which means a lot like in
computer chess as well because the more
time they spend on a position the better
moves they make so that's one of the
things they were saying that that's not
clear if that was fair or not
so they've played twice is that what's
happened yes I've heard with versions of
stockfish I don't know the versions I
don't remember the versions because it
feel like I read somewhere one like the
first time it was like stockfish eight
or something but by the time they had
like finished the match there was was it
a really long match in terms of it was a
hundred games I don't know how long it
took but it was a hundred games
well yeah it's but it's like by the time
the metros ended stalkerish mind was out
or some other stuff yeah something like
that
oh man here you read all that that's too
much the developer said yeah you just
give up on that comment it's just it's
probably really important to the topic
to the Masters on the developer said the
match results by themselves are not
particularly meaningful because of the
rather strange choice of time controls
in stockfish parameter setting the games
were played at a fixed time of one
minute per move which means that
stockfish has no use of its time
management heuristics a lot of effort
has been putting into making stockfish
identified critical points in the game
and decide when to spend some of its
extra time on a move and a fixed time
per move the strength will suffer
significantly Thank You Zeo
Rhett's for that incredibly long coming
did you understand any of that no I did
have a response I don't really have a
response for that but
I can tell you that Jakob Wilkins will
be able to give us some background on
this and giving us something to talk
about here because he can tell us how
the computers work how much time
actually matters or not
yes I'm interesting to go to view
because he's he's really invested yeah
he's invested in this and he's he knows
what's going on there so I think it will
be a worth a watch do you do when you're
filming it is it is this gonna be a live
stream of it this is going to be a live
stream event so feel free to join in it
will be around the end of January as far
as I know okay yeah we'll have to update
you as we gather what the exact yeah but
tentatively it's around the end of
January so if you have any opinion
thoughts who you don't like have you
watched the most recent Marilyn Manson
video that's not necessarily related
what I'm interested would you accept a
bull game what oh this feels like the
point of the stream where maybe we can
sneak one in yeah alpha0 did not play on
5000 teepee use they played on four
teepee use again stock fish on 44 course
all the stuff is beyond me but yeah
hopefully it makes sense to to you and
Jacob yeah I mean Jacob will you'll know
exactly you'll know what's going on yeah
oh my god this is looking horrible I
don't know this is not good
alright I'm not worried you're the best
worried well if your worst soviet
sacrifice that was intentional yes
and claim to sacrifice a nail let's get
our pieces out so my Joe Cole yep again
what was happening of craziness
all right hmm all right let's let's go
he places great so are you gonna wind up
I don't know if I'm gonna wind but maybe
maybe maybe
what's your threat
a pleasant illusion is watching us thank
you
pleasant and lovely any advantage White
has it's a pleasant illusion yes
position but we do have a threat well
yeah but I don't want to spoil it
okay just yet yeah so how about after
this do you get two more games in yeah
okay I think that's probably a
reasonable so there's still time
get your challenges in five minutes or
less whatever you guys are into we'll
get a look at two more good to see you
Luke hazard also tell us which state are
you from yeah I want to know really want
to know this is unpleasant
okay let's do this
oh oh he turned on the engine okay it's
not fun what didn't he well we'll see
you know this is too hard work related
stuff yep
Brooke related problems look probably we
got a yeah our technical director has
phoned me in also he's right there so he
could just yell cuz okay
it feels really formal cuz we got the
right answer but we're still yeah this
is some jokey stream live shouldn't be
taken too serious but uh who cares about
alpha zero which is the name of your
stream we'll be streaming on the 26th at
3:00 p.m. so everybody will want to mark
it on the calendar I assume that's a
Thursday no one can confirm that for
sure no one can come but yeah yeah
they're 26 3 p.m. Central Time
be there or know nothing about topic
it's up to you hmm boy so much stuff
going on here there's still always flag
or tuna tease like I turn it it's like
it's yeah I think that's a word so is an
option flagging is always an option
sadly yes okay I have like 15 per may
have like 50 fonts so maybe that's a bad
thing
righty let's go here
let's go here let's go here that's cool
here all right he's gonna Queen look
check that's cool here I'm sure this is
amazing for me but it's not horrible
feels bad feels bad brother feels bad
but yeah ii stuffy and i make sure this
is fine for me because this pawn is
worth like 50 queens 50 queens 50 Queens
now this offer is so generous I can't
refuse but I'm do this
wow you trickster take it yeah I think
it thank you this was the toughest game
look no foe it was a tough game very
tough to thank you for the fight alright
okay so so yeah let's finish with one
more and then as you guys can see there
on your stream 34 I guess I don't know
if you played it we played them before
where we give them another game quantex
he's a good game
no how can i play alright no oh yeah
just wait d43 amongst people
gambits okay there i think this is a
gambit yeah only if he takes it you can
see there our stream schedule so on
tuesdays usually it is me doing it at 12
p.m. so this is like a pseudo Italian I
did post my bishop on see everybody's
happy a gambit and an attempt ok so
let's make it even more crazy yeah
another party stop singing
let's do but I'll be on vacation for two
weeks so you will not see me next
Tuesday but you know there's a very
adequate substitute most likely ash
runts just taken up so on because that's
funny yeah and then on Wednesdays
normally we get Ryan Chester in here at
3 p.m.
Thursdays at 3 p.m. we have the GM
Rebecca's here just in time to say
goodbye to the stream yeah you have to
get a little closer yeah just go Raven
between us and you should make by
Rebecca Rebecca was here she kicked it
off I'm sorry I suck so bad but
next next alright yeah we'll get Rebecca
back on the stream sometime it was a
pleasure Fridays at 2:30 p.m. though
that's what it's all about that's
tomorrow you do want to tune in
cuz it's Mike comer you holdin it down
crushing everybody he usually plays
one-minute games it's the most exciting
that's what it's all about
so do tune in and yeah we love playing
you guys yeah I mean again I respect the
chat everyone's been very good no trolls
yeah every day I get to say it you guys
have been good no trolls it makes it
easy for us yeah I have no reasons to
cry tonight so thank you so much all
right Rebecca you look like some actress
people can't put their finger on it I
don't watch out he has a threat oh my
god yeah I thought you were checking me
to there I also thought you played 95 oh
yeah all right
Beth's here just in time to say goodbye
to the stream natural just play badly
yeah there's most people Naturals just
bad players and we appreciate it cuz we
want all your rating points the Mike
Ness Monster is coming tomorrow
Mike this month Rebecca Harris is the
one Rebecca it looks like so how would
you rate this stream is it a one to ten
yeah wants a thumbs down okay let's do a
thumbs up thumbs down
that's um drunk lifeguard he's our troll
that's something I'm at least one troll
so I always got that Luke hazard always
a pleasure
we're trying to see a lot of the same
names we're getting a lot of these
people Oh Ryan he's been around Neal
medic he's been around neo medic yeah
he's a new medical stuff yeah it's gonna
know angry yeah I mean the scary Oh Beth
is here yes better say goodbye to the
stream yep just come and enamine us so
that they see you on the thing you have
to you know like in between us
all right one yeah and sadly this night
is pinned therefore that's night night
for though hey Jess well they chest
control us if it makes us feel better
a little trolling nothing out of line
but just a little better it just feels
like do they even respect us if they're
not rolling
we'll see ya boost Pleasant illusion
Rebecca Harris is narrowed its key isn't
there this how did you think this is
username okay love hey chess thank you
very much that's controlling neo medic
saying stuff it's Daniel I don't know
what people are talking about anymore
you know I've lost the threat of what
people are talking about okay so that's
a focus mode here that's checkmate the
King in the Senate the natural
checkpoint let's do this let's do this
are you up a piece just in case it's not
checkmate it is you're winning a queen
just in case thank you in one segment
one checkmate yes all right well yeah
Thank You quantex and obviously Thank
You Dennis Lee the brilliant stream
undefeated he crushed everyone took all
the rating points yeah that's your job
that's what you did and there's anything
you want to say before we we head out of
here yes it was fun hanging out with you
guys and if you have music suggestions
or any anything you want to talk about
just alright send messages yeah and come
back tomorrow at 2:30 p.m. Central time
for some Mike comer action we'll see you
guys then having a Vegas